So
Jacob and Esau are,
are hostile brothers there.
They're like Cain and Abel except the
mixture of Cain and Abel.
And they're very different.
Esau was red and covered with hair.
He was a hunter and a man of the field.
So he's like your basic joc,
right?
He's extroverted,
he's outgoing,
he's really tough.
He's extraordinarily masculine,
he hunts and he's a real favorite of his
father.
And so,
and,
and Jacob isn't,
he's a dweller intense and um,
yeah,
right,
exactly.
Exactly.
Exactly right.
And it says Isaac loved Esau,
but Rebecca loved Jacob.
Now that's a problem,
right?
That that's a big problem.
And that there's a Friday in element to
this.
It's like this family is now divided
because one child is the favorite of the
mother and that's Jacob.
And one child is the favorite of the
father.
And so Jacob is kind of a mother's boy,
I guess to use an arc or rather archaic
phrase and certainly not as admirable
from his father's perspective as Esau,
who a tough guy who goes out with a bow
and Arrow and like,
you know,
wanders around in the plains and brings
animals home.
And,
and he's tough.
He's a tough guy.
So,
and,
but,
but there's this discord in the family
because one parent prefers one child and
the other parent prefers the other.
And it's obvious from the story that the
parents do not communicate about this
because they really take sides.
And so there's a split in the family and
that's I think very realistic because
one of the things that you do learn if
you have a family,
and of course most of you do,
but if you also think about families is
that there's,
there's deep divisions within families
very,
very frequently that no one will ever
talk about and,
or even think about often because it's
too painful to think about,
you know,
Freud himself said Freud was clearly his
mother's favorite and the family
sacrificed a lot,
including some of the potential
ambitions of the other children in order
to kind of put Sigmund Freud up on a
pedestal and,
and advanced is education.
And it worked.
I mean,
you know,
he,
he turned into a great man,
but there was a cost to his siblings and
Freud himself said that there was
something about being the favorite of
the mother that gave a person additional
confidence throughout their life.
And you know,
there's,
there's something to be said about that
is when someone like Eric Erikson,
you know,
he noted that very interested in child
development,
that that first bonding with the mother
was the,
was it the place where trust was
established,
maybe trust even in the goodness of
existence was established.
And so anyways,
Jacob is Rachel's favorite and uh,
yeah,
Esau is Isaac's favorite.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now eso being extroverted let's say is
also a bit impulsive and maybe he's not,
he's a man of action.
He's not a forward thinker,
but he's also doing hard work.
And so,
you know,
he goes out and he's hunting and he's
worn out and he comes home and he's
faint with hunger.
And
Jacob is at home,
cooking is boiling up,
lentils,
red lentils,
and you know,
Esau comes in from the haunt and eats
like half starved to death.
And he's sitting there and the aroma of
these red lentils reaches them and he's
exhausted.
And,
and,
and he tells Jacob that he wants some of
this stew and Jacob who's being a pain
in the neck,
fundamentally,
they have basically says,
no,
there's a,
there's a teasing thing going on here
and,
and won't give him any.
And,
and,
and there's,
you have to imagine this because it's
not laid out explicitly in the story,
but there's some dispute about whether
Esau gets to have lunch.
And Jacob finally says,
well,
I'll give you some,
but you have to s you have to give me
your birthright.
And you saw,
you think he might say something like,
you know,
well,
to hell with it,
take it,
you know,
you son of a bitch,
take it.
Just give me some damn stew.
It's something like that.
So that's what happens.
But you know,
with these archaic people,
once he made a statement like that,
that was,
you were done.
That was it.
And so,
um,
east south sells his birthright and this
turns out to be incredibly significant.
Benson who wrote Biblical commentary
said,
Oh,
there's a bit of a twist to it.
So Esau eats the,
the red lentils and then from then on,
his name is red.
And you've got to use your imagination a
bit.
I mean,
people are making fun of him,
right?
That's why they're calling them red.
I mean,
he's already read because we established
that,
but no one was calling him read before
this.
And so for the rest of his life,
you know,
every time he goes out amongst his
friends and family,
they call them red and sort of snicker
because he's the,
you know,
half famished idiot who sold his
birthright for a bowl of lentils.
And so it's,
it's not,
it's not that funny actually.
And so Esau is not happy about this.
And,
and it actually turns out that this,
so what does it mean?
It means don't sell the future for the
desires of the present and don't be
casual about what you have.
And then there's an archetype element to
this too.
And Benson says,
various have been the opinions what this
birthright was,
which Esau sold.
But the most probable is that together
with the right of sacrificing,
so determining what should be sacrificed
and win and being the priest of the
family,
it included the peculiar blessing
promised to the seed of Abraham,
that of being the progenitor of the
Messiah and the error of the special
promises of God,
respecting Christ's kingdom.
It was at least typical of spiritual
privileges.
Those of the firstborn that are written
in heaven.
Well,
that's a lot harsher than meets the eye
to begin with.
And so there's a very interesting deep
moral story there,
which is,
it's sort of Esau does the opposite of a
sacrifice.
It's the reverse,
right?
He sacrifices the future for the
present.
And so the,
the,
the story basically says,
the way it's laid out across stories is
that if you're the sort of person that
sacrifices the future to the present,
then that eradicates the possibility
that you will bring the most noble being
into existence.
That's what it means.
And you can,
again,
this is the psychological significance
of the biblical story.
So that's a bad thing to do if you want
to realize your potential.
Let's say you don't do reverse
sacrifices.
That's a very bad idea.
And so east,
so really did himself in by being too
attached to the present without a vision
of the future.
So he's too in the moment,
you know,
and,
and he pays a heavy price for it.
I mean,
he's the,
first of all,
he loses his birthright and has double
inheritance.
So there's a practical consequence.
And then there's a spiritual
consequence.
And then he's,
while he's being made a fool of by his
brother,
Jacob means supplanter by the way,
that's what the name means.
And Jacob has always trying to usurp
Esau as,
as we see.
And so Jacob gets one over on him and
you know,
that's not,
doesn't make an older brother happy when
a younger brother gets something over on
them,
that's for sure.
And then he loses the opportunity to be
the progenitor of the Messiah,
which is like,
he probably didn't realize that
precisely,
but it seems to be,
you know,
it's kind of rough that so.